salve era abbastanza sorpresa non me
l'aspettavo
adesso fra un po e scende and game
sapete qual è la cosa bella di vivere
nel mio cervello è che io sono staccato
dalla maggior parte delle cose io guardo
le cose da fuori per esempio nel marvel
cinematic universe e io non sono
appassionato ma mi piacciono i film
action il problema del marvel fine matic
universe è che a un certo punto mi sono
rotto i [ __ ] e so per certo che un
sacco di altra gente la pensa così poi
voglio dire sono fumetti è roba per
bambini no tutti i registi di film i
fumetti sono tutti i [ __ ] ti i
disegnatori di fumetti non fanno un vero
lavoro
però poi cosa succede succede infinity
ward
succede che un film è effettivamente
bello ed effettivamente spettacolare e
due ore e mezza muore 40 di film volano
via come se fossero dieci minuti ma un
sacco di gente non avviso perché si è
rotta il cazzo prima siccome arriverà
and game e sicuramente sarà bello perché
il seguito di infinity ward vi riassumo
io tutto il marvel cinematic universe
dio che una sola persona a cui viene
frega relativamente non sono fan della
marvel ma mi piacciono i film di merda
action trash infatti uno dei miei
registi preferiti e michael bay
l'ho detto non può fare non fare facile
quindi vi riassumo io con tanto di sette
props che vedrete tutto il marvel
cinematic universe in modo che voi
possiate non farlo
[Musica]
ho sputato tantissimo tutto il tempo
iron man
la particolarità di questi film di tutti
fini del marvel segnalati più diverse e
che hanno una marea di attori the stars
famosissimi ogni singolo film
incredibile per esempio in questo c'è
jeff bridges perché in questo film
robert downey junior ve lo ricorderete
perché è quello che prima del marvel su
una tv universi drogava andava in
prigione diventa ricco lo rapiscono gli
arabi ma siccome noi è molto molto ricco
e molto molto intelligente riesce a
scappare
dentro una caffettiera e gli americani
vincono hulk
io non sono sicurissimo che questo film
conti per davvero però edward norton che
fa hulk e poi cambia e c'è tim roth nel
film e ci sono c'è hulk è un altro
mostro che fa tim roth e si picchiano
fortissimo e poi dice iron man 2
c'è mickey rourke a montecarlo che si
vuole vendicare di iron man e lo mela
con due fruste elettriche su una pista
di formula 1 non so
tra l'altro in questo film c'è war
machine che cambiato ed è più nero del
primo film non si torna c'è anthony
hopkins un'idea di come facciano a
premere questi attori li pagano e anche
natalie portman che voglio dire poi
anthony hopkins era anche in
transformers quindi voglio dire c'è thor
che viene scaraventato sulla terra
perché una testa di cazzo
fondamentalmente perché non è degno poi
durante il film ridiventa degno e il
film finisce dalla fine del film arriva
samuel jackson che nick fury che recluta
tutti gli avengers piano piano
capitan america c'è una specie di bobble
head di chris evans ha un effetto
speciale della merda dove lui è super
magro ma una testa gigantesca però poi
fortunatamente lo sostituiscono con il
vero capitan america e nel film ci sono
sia tommy lee jones sia vvv weaving e
tra l'altro hugo weaving fa la parte del
nemico di capitan america teschio rosso
il film è pieno zeppo di nazisti e gli
americani vincono le cose fondamentali
del film sono 21 e che teschio rosso
viene sparato nella stratosfera ed è
molto importante a quanto pare per
qualche motivo tipo il team rocket che
fallisce la missione ma soprattutto
viene introdotto in questo film
il tesseract te l'ho detto che non ne
valeva avengers è invecchiato veramente
male sembra un film degli ultimi anni 90
circa
ma magari fatto apposta e quindi meno
male ci sono tutti quanti che lottano
contro due blocchi
eccolo qui e loki arrivare delle
creature orripilanti su degli skateboard
fatti di luce che cazzo siano di
tecnologia con dei vermoni enormi ma gli
americani
la cosa importante è che tony stark va
nello sport nello spazio va da lui come
maometto
nello spazio e cosa molto importante si
vede thanos nella classica posa del ho
fatto gol
per la prima volta è qui tra l'altro
finisce la prima fase dell'universo ma
siccome state guardando questo video
perché ve ne sbatte i [ __ ] e faccio
a meno di dirmelo
aicon mentre
qui ci sono delle turbe brutte brutte
che tornano in testa a tony stark il
cattivo in questo film è un nemico che
si chiama il mandarino ma il colpo di
scena è che quello che ha fatto anche
rompere il cazzo tutti quelli che sono
andati al cinema a vederlo e che in
realtà il mandarino non è veramente il
mandarino in realtà il vero nemico e guy
pearce
non so quanti soldi abbiano per riuscire
a prendere questi attori per oggi
torture questo è un film di merda detto
da tutti un film di merda inutile brutto
inutilmente costoso e fa cagare
ma incredibilmente a un voto più alto su
rottentomatoes di voi mi e rhapsody è
che se vuoi fare
crawford in questo film appare per la
prima volta la prima gemma dell'infinito
che sparirà a breve
capitan america the winter soldier qui
c'è capitan america che picchia
fortissimo il suo ex migliore amico un
po come pretty little liars che diventa
immediatamente cattivo vedi così e nel
film c'è robert redford e per la prima
volta in tutta la saga una trama
guardiani della galassia nel montaggio
probabilmente lo vedrete mettere un
sacco di luci e colori strobo e gli anni
ottanta e la musica degli anni 80 perché
alla gente piace è qui presentano tra
l'altro i personaggi più più
interessanti diciamo dicono che sia uno
dei film più belli del marvel signora
tic universe e ci sono come vedete
questa squadra nello spaccio tipo power
rangers in space che sono quello con la
maschera she hulk l'albero quello del
signore degli anelli poi purtroppo io ho
comprato i set i playset della disney e
c'era il playset dei guardiani della
galassia ma dentro non c'erano nervo che
tra cui è né battista ho dovuto far
meglio questo battista si legge di
animal solo le mutande grazie avengers e
john questo fin qui
e girato in valle d'aosta qui c'è una
cazzata incredibile c'è tony stark che
crea un robottone che gli si rivolta
contro e tra l'altro si ricarica via usb
è un'arma terribile veloce è così che ne
sono questi son della marvel lo sapranno
e tra l'altro ci sono due in tanti in
questo film ma che per i diritti della
fox non possono chiamare i mutanti e
quindi mi chiamano al cos'altro
e qui nasce un altro personaggio molto
importante visione visione nasce come la
banana chiquita con la pietra
dell'infinito verde se non mi ricordo
male in testa
eccola qui era già la vedi introduciamo
quiksilver e scarlett che permette nel
pack della disney non c'erano quindi
immaginate una i capelli rossi l'altro è
super velocissimo ed è talmente veloce
quiksilver che viene crivellato e muore
la cosa bella non so se lo sapevate in
due attori che fanno scarlett e qui
silver che sono fratelli
nel film sono gli stessi attori che nel
film di godzilla sono marito e moglie
e chissenefrega va beh scusate ma alla
fine la cosa più importante thanos
prende il guanto dell'infinito è una
presina da cucina e c'era un cartellino
con scritto non avvicinare a fonti di
calore
una presina and men te l'ho detto io
nella nostra testa era molto meglio
c'è un uomo piccolissimo in questo film
vestito da formica che lotta contro un
altro uomo piccolissimo vestito da
calabrone c'è uno degli effetti speciali
più belli della storia del cinema ed è
sulla faccia di michael douglas film a
livello di trama e tipo una promessa è
una promessa mischiato a tesoro mi si
sono ristretti i ragazzi con un pizzino
di a bug's life ma mi stavo dimenticando
capitan america civil war
non so perché questo non sia avengers
trema sia capitan america civil muore
quindi capitan america civil board è il
film di capitan america ma ci sono tutti
quanti
e tra l'altro è la prima volta che si
vedono black panther e spiderman
definito da tutti preferivo tobey
maguire dottor strange inizia che
praticamente una puntata di ar
poi noi se vedete qui si fa male alle
mani va da uno di quei santoni di
striscia la notizia ma a sto giro
funziona incredibilmente il santone e
noi diventa già i poteri poi diventa un
po inception anche un pochino c'è come
nemico mads mikkelsen lottano croma
inception e e muore e lui vive e vince
e qui appare la gemma dell'infinito
verde ci siete resi per ora ci siede
perfetto guardiani della galassia 20
piccolo piccolo e non c'era ci sono loro
e c'è lui che ha problemi con suo padre
col padre carlo ci sono problemi gravi e
tra l'altro il film ed è talmente
inutile che spider man homecoming pensa
costumi di spiderman cerno ma non so che
tra con e battista mentre record e non
lo so perché comunque preferivo tobey
maguire e finalmente nel sesto film di
spider man non lo zio ben
c'è peter che va in gita scolastica e
viene attaccato da michael keaton quello
di man
come vedete qui nella sua
rappresentazione in tiber ben e c'è
anche iron man thor 3 e quando ho capito
che non sono fan della serie perché a me
è piaciuto un sacco boom ci sono torre
sono hulk tra l'altro nella versione
planet hulk quello l'ho letto il fumetto
me lo ricordo infatti è stato figo da
vedere si menano anche se sono amici ci
sono un sacco di risate perché non gli
non volevano più farli drammatici perché
hanno visto che i film della dis i
drammatici faceva cagare la merda e
quindi ha detto facciamolo superf anni
perché i guardiani della galassia dalla
ricordi moroni nothing stronzo anni
ottanta fa ha fatto molto successo
invece questo no e mortacci vostra
perché a me è piaciuto e c'è che plance
come in questo film distruggono tutto
arriva il ragnarok di sugano asgard
ma poi va tutto bene se idris elba prima
che la gente sapesse chi fosse ma
soprattutto incontro talos black panther
c'è batman straight auto wakanda batman
diventare al mazza creed e di vince e
decide di aprire i porti tra l'altro 97
per cento su rotten tomatoes non capisco
un cazzo ignora coadiuvare di film 27
news della vd 3 e poi
indovinate chi è martin freeman nel film
infinity ward i vendicatori fanno di
tutto per impedire a palos e schioccare
le dita ma lui le schiocca
[Musica]
e gran finale però poi ne ho fatto altri
due film dopo quindi devo ricostruire il
sesto adesso un attimo solo ant man 2 il
film è completamente inutile però lui
rimane bloccato nel mondo quantico e io
non ho un 7 del mondo quanti proprio che
non so come sia fatto però è importante
questa cosa qua perché probabilmente ci
sarà fuori per il game e salverà tutti
capital marvel o anche capitan ma la
versione del fumetto ma ho anche capitan
marvel fate finta che questi siano
crilin è fortissima viene addestrata dai
creek sono poi quelli di secret world i
secret invasion
non mi ricordo va beh uno dei due voi
andate a cercare però lei è in realtà
umana colpo di scena e umana che ha il
potere di una gemma dell'infinito che è
di colore giusto l'unica che manca è il
test delle battute terribili sul fatto
che sia una pastiglia della
lavastoviglie lavatrice con la povera
capital marvel però si scopre che jude
law e il cattivo come fino all'ultimo e
c'è sangue del jackson e ringiovanito
anche lui solo che come loro i giovani
c'è lui dietro gli le rughe nella
capelli ai capelli è giusto che li
mettono e giustamente e a quanto pare il
twist one è che non è capitan marvel non
sono ichri non è il tester act e non è
samuel jackson che vincerà la marvel ma
che vincerà tutta la guerra spoiler e
quindi eccoci qui e ora assunto il
marvel 6 matic universe in poche parole
e da uno a cui non gliene frega molto
del mar ven cinematic universe ma
semplicemente un appassionato di film
action io non vedo l'ora effettivamente
che crolli new york e esca endgame però
non perché a me dispiace che gente come
me che ad angelo da dentro basso mi sono
rotto i [ __ ] vedere film di
supereroi con la tutina però in realtà
magari con infinity ward vi siete persi
dei gran bei film secondo e quindi noi
non fate come me non siate [ __ ] con
me io mi ricordo che ho
30 anni 31 quest'anno questo quindi
bocciato
[Musica]